Transcriptor: Yonara Anastacio
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Sacrificio.
Es una palabra que evoca el silencio.
El silencio de la soledad,
el miedo y las preocupaciones.
Pero también la superación,
la esperanza y la aceptación.
Hoy quiero contarles una historia,
una historia real.
De las que tal vez han escuchado
en algún sitio y no consiguen recordar,
porque la han aparcado
en algún lugar de la mente,
para decirse en silencio
y en voz bajita: “No me ha pasado a mí“.
Juan es un hombre de mediana edad,
con unos ojos verdes preciosos,
una mirada penetrante y profunda
de las que es difícil olvidar.
Es una persona testaruda,
independiente y muy inteligente.
Hará cerca de un año y medio comenzó
a notar un entumecimiento en sus manos,
después calambres
que le recorrían los brazos
Y en poco tiempo,
su agilidad ya no era la misma.
Al principio no revestía gravedad.
Juan y su mujer, Maricarmen, decidieron
que era el momento de ir al médico.
Pasaron cerca de dos meses
de hospital en hospital,
hasta que un día, en una sala blanca,
el médico le dijo:
“Juan, usted padece
esclerosis lateral amiotrófica”.
En ese momento se paró el tiempo.
Juan sintió un gran alivio.
Por fin sabía lo que tenía.
Por fin le podían tratar.
Sin embargo, instantes después,
el neurólogo le dijo: “Lo siento”.
“¿Lo siento? ¿Cómo que lo siento?”
Fue incapaz de entender esas dos palabras
y la realidad es que necesitó
cerca de dos meses, tan solo
para poder comprender dos palabras.
Me voy a morir. Sí, me voy a morir.
¿Se imaginan Uds. por un instante,
por un segundo, cómo se sintió Juan?
Saber que padecen una enfermedad incurable
que les agarrará de la mano
y les llevará inexorablemente
por un camino que tiene un fin.
No hay palabras, tan solo el silencio.
Me llamo Carmen.
Y soy investigadora.
Hoy me gustaría compartir
con Uds. mi propia historia.
Pero no porque sea importante,
sino porque mi trabajo,
al igual que el de muchos investigadores
como yo, es decisivo para la vida de Juan.
Desde pequeña
siempre quise ser científica,
dedicarme a esta profesión.
Contribuir a ayudar a los demás,
a personas que padecen
enfermedades que nunca he visto.
No imagino sus caras, no sé quiénes son.
Sin embargo, tenemos que ser conscientes
de que es una realidad de todos.
A todos nos puede tocar.
En esta ocasión tan especial,
tengo el enorme privilegio de compartir
este escenario, este espacio,
con personas y profesionales que,
como yo, han dedicado y dedican su vida
a un objetivo común: contribuir
positivamente a nuestra sociedad.
Contribuir positivamente
a nuestra sociedad.
No puedo hablar por boca de todos.
Tampoco lo pretendo.
Pero tal vez aquí hoy,
de la mano de mi propia historia,
pueda ser capaz de hablar
por boca de algunos.
Quién sabe si tal vez por boca de muchos,
muchos que como yo, desde corta edad
sintieron vocación,
amor por esta profesión.
Personas jóvenes, que tras su paso
por la universidad,
vieron y concibieron la ciencia
como algo al servicio de los demás.
La investigación requiere sacrificio,
un enorme sacrificio personal.
Saber que tenemos que estar preparados
para conceder mucho
de nuestro tiempo libre
a un único fin, una única lucha.
Un único fin y una única lucha.
Ser investigador requiere
sacrificio, perseverancia.
Créanme que no es un camino fácil,
un camino en ocasiones lleno de obstáculos
y muchas veces los objetivos que obtenemos
no son los que desearíamos.
Los objetivos que obtenemos
no son los que desearíamos
Ser investigador requiere sacrificio.
La carrera de un científico comienza
con la realización de una tesis doctoral.
Créanme que ya en este punto
tengo que retomar
el concepto de la palabra “sacrificio”,
porque hay que tener muy buenas notas
para poder conseguir una beca doctoral.
Y esta es la principal barrera
a la que se enfrentan nuestros jóvenes,
cuando quieren dedicar su vida
a la investigación.
Desde la posición
que ocupo en la actualidad,
a día de hoy veo cada vez
más importante el cambio.
Nuestros jóvenes, que intentan alcanzar
esa meta, se ven sometidos
a elevados estándares,
objetivos a veces inalcanzables
y no podemos caer en el error
de perder a nuestros jóvenes.
Talento que irá a contribuir al progreso
de las sociedades en otros países.
No nos lo podemos permitir.
En mi caso fui afortunada, y digo
afortunada y tal vez que no tuve suerte,
porque muchas veces la suerte
y el sacrificio son caminos
que van totalmente separados.
Sin embargo, he conseguido progresar
cada día en mis objetivos
y por eso me siento afortunada.
Conseguí una beca predoctoral
en Castilla-La Mancha,
para realizar mi tesis doctoral
en Toledo, mi ciudad natal.
Hasta ahí llegué
después de mucho esfuerzo,
tras conseguir unas altas
calificaciones en la universidad.
No fue fácil.
Creo que como para la mayoría.
Tal vez por dos motivos fundamentales:
el primero, la edad.
Tan solo tenía 22 años.
Y el segundo, porque ya desde ese camino,
desde ese inicio,
somos conscientes de la responsabilidad
del camino que vamos a emprender.
Cuando terminé mi tesis doctoral,
a finales del año 2007,
me incorporé a un laboratorio
en el Hospital Nacional
de Parapléjicos de Toledo,
donde permanecí casi siete años.
Y ya como doctor completé mi periodo
de formación postdoctoral
como investigador junior.
A finales del año 2012,
tuve el enorme privilegio
de ser reclutada por un centro
de investigación en Tasmania, Australia.
Un centro de investigación
pionero en el mundo
en el campo de estudio de las
enfermedades neurodegenerativas,
particularmente las demencias y
otros trastornos neurológicos como la ELA.
Me marché a principios del año 2013
junto con mi marido, llena de ilusión
y de entusiasmo
por afrontar ese gran reto.
Sin embargo, fue un año muy duro.
Un primer año complicado, un cambio
cultural, un cambio de idioma,
y sobre todo, estar lejos
de mi familia y de mis amigos.
Fue un año de un enorme esfuerzo personal.
Sin embargo, después de cuatro años
no solo aprendí mucho y crecí
a nivel científico, también a nivel
personal y me formé en el liderazgo.
Algo que es prioritario y fundamental
en nuestro desarrollo profesional.
En algunas ocasiones he oído comentarios
de personas que piensan
que hay muchas más oportunidades
en el extranjero.
Créanme, tal vez no lo puedo negar.
Sin embargo, también tengo que contarles
que requiere de un enorme sacrificio
y esfuerzo personal, no solo nuestro,
sino también de nuestras familias.
Estoy segura de que aquí hoy en esta sala,
hay padres y madres
que tienen a sus hijos lejos.
Y aunque entiendo que respetan
sus opiniones y les apoyan,
también sienten miedo.
Porque somos capaces, en esa persecución,
en la necesidad de ir adquiriendo metas
y conseguir ese objetivo,
de hacer de nuestros deseos el de otros
y arrastrar hacia ellos
a nuestras familias
y a nuestros seres queridos.
Me van a permitir que les diga
que tengo amigos, conocidos
y personas que se han puesto
enfermas estando yo lejos,
parejas y matrimonios que se han roto.
Y en eso yo no fui una excepción.
Me marché a Australia sin saber que sería
la última vez que vería a mi padre.
No me pude despedir de él.
Fue muy duro, pero también
fue toda una enseñanza de vida.
Un gran aprendizaje para mí.
Estando lejos,
aprendí la importancia de la vida
y también la importancia de la muerte.
Y casi al mismo tiempo que iniciaba
mi duelo y aceptaba la muerte de mi padre,
también fui madre.
Mi hijo mayor, Lucas, tiene cinco años,
y mi hija pequeña, Martina,
cumplirá cuatro ahora en julio.
Ellos son lo más maravilloso
de mi vida, mi orgullo.
Pero no estoy aquí
para hablarles hoy de ellos.
Eso sería toda una charla aparte.
A finales del año 2016, volví a España
con mi hijo de tan solo cuatro meses.
Tengo que confesarles que sin querer,
mi marido tuvo una enorme oportunidad
de desarrollo profesional
y no me pude negar.
No podía decirle no
a quien dejó todo para seguirme.
Sin embargo, volví a España
con la misma alegría, la misma inquietud
y las mismas ganas de afrontar el reto
de continuar con mi investigación
en Toledo, mi ciudad natal.
Desde finales del año 2018
tengo el privilegio de poder dirigir
una línea de investigación en ELA,
aquí en Castilla-La Mancha.
También un laboratorio
en el Hospital Nacional de Parapléjicos.
Somos un grupo pequeño, muy joven,
pero hemos recibido financiación
de importantes entidades,
que comprenden que es una necesidad
invertir en investigación para encontrar
una cura a esta terrible enfermedad.
Y desde aquí les doy las gracias.
Ahora solo hace falta que otras muchas
instituciones se sumen a esta lucha
y apoyen nuestro desarrollo profesional.
Gracias a este proyecto, he tenido
la grandísima oportunidad de conocer
a personas maravillosas, todos ellos
enfermos de ELA, hombres y mujeres,
jóvenes en su mayoría.
Ellos son mi motivación.
Personas que un día,
de la noche a la mañana,
vieron cómo sus vidas cambiaban
de una manera aleatoria.
¿Por qué ?
Personas que no sólo son mi motivación,
sino los que me dan fuerza
para seguir cada día.
Merecen todo mi respeto, personas llenas
de energía, con un enorme amor a la vida.
Tengo que decirles aquí hoy, que la ELA
ha sido considerada una enfermedad rara,
pero nuestra realidad hoy,
es que hay más de 3 000 personas en España
que padecen esta enfermedad y cada día
tres o cuatro personas son diagnosticadas
con esta terrible enfermedad.
Pero quiero transmitirles
un mensaje de esperanza.
La investigación es el camino.
Lo estamos consiguiendo
y estamos más cerca.
Juntos venceremos.
En este momento en el que estamos ahora,
tengo que decirles
que he llegado hasta aquí y soy lo que soy
no solo gracias al esfuerzo de mi familia,
que siempre me ha apoyado, también
al esfuerzo de mis mentores y mentoras,
personas que han contribuido
a mi formación,
que han sido generosas
y han permitido que esté aquí hoy.
La pandemia ha dejado
en nuestras mentes
imágenes horribles, historias terribles,
verdaderos dramas de familias
que perdurarán en nuestra mente
para siempre.
Serán y se convertirán
en un recuerdo generacional.
Pero también han puesto encima de la mesa
una realidad, una realidad que vivimos
los científicos como yo, que llevamos
toda una vida dedicada a esta profesión,
que no tenemos contratos estables,
y no sabemos si podremos seguir mañana
Es importante que las instituciones
sean conscientes
de que esto no es algo ocasional.
Es algo que está totalmente integrado
en nuestra cultura, en nuestra sociedad
y que tenemos que cambiar.
Las asociaciones de pacientes
han sido capaces de detectar esto
como una gran debilidad,
y se han acercado a nosotros
para ayudarnos a avanzar en el progreso,
en la medida de sus posibilidades.
Pero sobre todo, para junto con nosotros,
evitar que cada día
se sume un nuevo nombre,
una nueva vida rota,
una nueva familia.
Desde aquí les doy las gracias.
No puedo terminar esta charla
sin compartir con todos Uds.
algo muy personal.
La historia de una persona
que conocí hace años
y por la que siento
una enorme admiración personal.
Él, un enfermo de ELA, en un escenario
parecido al que estamos aquí hoy,
hace un tiempo tuvo la generosidad
de contarnos su historia.
Dejó una sala entera parecida a esta,
con los corazones de todos encogidos
y los ojos llenos de lágrimas,
al contar la terrible realidad
de esta enfermedad.
Pero fue todo un alegato a la vida,
una historia repleta de energía.
Él nos hablaba de hilos.
Hilos invisibles que le unían a la vida.
Hilos invisibles que le unían
a su familia, a sus amigos.
He querido hacer esta mención
especial desde el cariño
y sobre todo también
desde el mayor de mis respetos.
Él fue capaz de dar voz
a muchos enfermos con ELA
También a sus familias.
Y a mí me gustaría aquí hoy,
en este escenario de la mano de todos Uds.
generar un sentimiento
de solidaridad, de apoyo.
Realmente necesitamos un cambio, para que
la ciencia logre ser ese 2 % del PIB.
Pero sobre todo también, para que sea
un bien apreciado y valorado por todos.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)